- [Instructor] We finished the last video
in the year 40 B.C.E.,
where the year began
with the Parthian invasion of
Syria in the eastern provinces
of the Roman Republic, and
it really is an empire,
the Roman Republic or the Roman Empire.
But Marc Antony, who was
in control of the east
of the empire, he wasn't able
to deal with it immediately
because he goes to
Brundisium in order to take
his wife's side on a civil
war between her and Octavian.
Now, his wife dies and he
makes good with Octavian,
in fact, so good with Octavian,
he marries OCtavian's sister, Octavia,
and they decide, alright, let's
continue to be friends here
and they divide the Roman
Empire, the Roman Republic,
whatever you wanna call it, between them,
where Marc Antony keeps
control of the east,
you now have Octavian
with control over the west
and they gave Lepidus, who's always a bit
of the third wheel here, they gave him
some of the southern
provinces right over there.
Now it seems like all is good,
but as we've already talked about,
the tension between Antony
and Octavian is there,
it was there from the
beginning and in this video,
we're going to see that it
gets a lot, a lot worse.
So Marc Antony goes back to the east,
where he starts planning
his invasion of Parthia,
not only does he wanna
take back the territory
that they took in 40 B.C.E.,
but he actually wants
to avenge them for
Crassus' death in 53 B.C.E.
Julius Caesar had been
planning an invasion of Persia,
and you have to remember,
after Alexander the Great,
all of these western rulers,
especially the Romans,
they all had their sights
on Persia, they said,
"Hey, maybe I can be just
like Alexander the Great
"and take over the Persians."
So Marc Antony is planning
his invasion of Persia
but he doesn't get the troops
that he wants from Octavian
and so that starts to build
the tensions even further
but he goes to his lover,
Cleopatra, who is the richest
woman in the world, the
pharaoh of Egypt, and says,
"Hey can you give me
some Egyptian troops?"
And so he plans an
invasion of Parthian Persia
with a combined Roman and Egyptian troops.
Now unfortunately, that
is a failed invasion.
As they try to make their
way in, they get pretty far,
but they weren't able to
protect their supply lines
carefully and so the Parthians
are able to attack them,
attack their supply
lines and while they do,
the king of Armenia just kinda
doesn't really do anything
about it and so Marc
Antony is forced to retreat
and so you can imagine, he's
not too happy about this.
The Parthians in 40
B.C.E. were able to take
all of this territory, in 36 B.C.E.,
so now we are right
over here, in 36 B.C.E.,
we have a failed revenge
invasion of the Parthians,
he's betrayed by the Armenian king.
Now the other thing that's happening
is that Lepidus is now
out of the triumvirate.
He tries to do a little bit of a land grab
after him and Octavian go after
another governor in Sicily,
but when they're successful,
when Lepidus tries
to take control of Sicily,
Octavian says, "No no no no,
"not only can you not do that,
"but you're now out of the triumvirate."
So 36 B.C.E. is a situation where Octavian
continues to try to consolidate
his power in the west,
Lepidus is now out, and
Marc Antony faces another,
I guess you could say embarrassment
against the Parthians.
So then we get to 33 B.C.E.
So let's see, this is 33 B.C.E.
right over here on this map
and finally, he's able to
muster up enough of a force
to take not revenge on the Parthians,
but to take some of the
territory, but in particular,
to take revenge on the Armenian king.
And so Marc Antony, it's
his first win after awhile,
tries to make a lot of
this, and so when he goes,
he goes back to Alexandria,
where of course his lover
Cleopatra reigns, and there,
he has this big celebration
to say, "Hey look, I went and was able
"to take out the king of Armenia."
Now this celebration, it rubs
the Romans in a wrong way
on a whole bunch of dimensions.
One, they never really like Cleopatra,
they view her as a foreign
queen, they didn't like her
when she was Julius Caesar's
lover, they definitely
don't like her when she's
Marc Antony's lover,
and they're kind of peeved that
he decides to go Alexandria
and do this ceremonial victory party
that typically only happened in Rome,
it looks like this guy doesn't really
even view himself as Roman anymore.
He likes to go back to Alexandria.
And the real salt that he rubbed,
especially in Octavian's wounds,
was a speech he gave
which will later be known
as the Donations of Alexandria.
So what he starts doing
is putting his children,
especially the children
that he has with Cleopatra,
as the rulers of a lot
of the eastern provinces.
But the worst thing that
he does, is in that speech,
in the Donations of Alexandria,
this is in 33 B.C.E.,
right over here, he declares
that Cleopatra's son
that was apparently the
son of Julius Caesar,
Caesarion, that he is the
rightful heir to Julius Caesar.
Now, Octavian does not like this, he says,
"Hey, I'm the adopted son,
I'm the rightful heir,
"I don't like this Caesarion guy."
And so for the next few
years, in 33 and 32 B.C.E.,
so we're in this period on that timeline,
we're in this period on this timeline,
tensions start to get
a lot, lot, lot worse
between Octavian and Marc Antony,
they are publicly accusing
each other of not even being
legitimate people with
legitimate authority,
they are really starting
to question each other,
they're really starting
to go at each other.
And it all culminates in 31 B.C.E.,
it all culminates in 31
B.C.E., so this is where we are
right over here, with the
naval battle at Actium.
And for the most part, and
Marc Antony and Cleopatra
are both there, and
they're on their heels,
they're surrounded by
the forces of Octavian,
and the best that they can
hope for is just an escape
and Antony and Cleopatra
are able to escape
and it's very clear from that battle
that they really only cared
about saving their own hides
and their own wealth, and they
left the most of their navy,
they returned with only
60 boats to Alexandria
but they leave most of
their navy to kind of
have to deal with the forces of Octavian.
So they were already on their heels,
they have this escape in 31 B.C.E.,
many historians will call
the Battle of Actium,
and this is a depiction of
the naval battle at Actium
right over here, as the end, after this,
there was no chance, really,
for Cleopatra and Marc Antony
in any way, to rival Octavian,
that Octavian was now
the real sole power in what is evolving
from a Roman Republic to a Roman Empire.
But Antony and Cleopatra,
maybe they didn't realize it
as much, they go back to
Alexandria and continue to plot,
seeing how they can get back at Octavian.
So Octavian doesn't want much of this,
so he decides to go attack
them in Alexandria in 30 B.C.E.
And Antony tries to make a
last stand against Octavian
but his soldiers really
aren't in the mood to fight
so he goes back to the palace,
he looks for Cleopatra,
Cleopatra gets one of her
servants to tell Marc Antony,
'cause she has no mood to
see him, because who knows,
he's raving mad, he might
wanna kill her or kill him,
who knows what he might wanna do,
Cleopatra had her servant tell Marc Antony
that Cleopatra was dead
and so Marc Antony,
he's already down, his
soldiers have deserted him,
there's no way for him to take
on Octavian, he's essentially
lost, and now Cleopatra, his
lover, is apparently dead.
He stabs himself
repeatedly in the stomach.
Now, Cleopatra finds out about
this and then she has Marc
Antony brought to him, he
doesn't die immediately,
stabbing yourself in the stomach is a way
of having a very slow and painful death.
And he dies essentially in her arms.
And then Cleopatra is
taken, then, by the forces
of Octavian, but then she too decides
that she wants to commit
suicide or at least
that's what most accounts say
and the most common account
is that she gets a snake
smuggled into her rooms,
a poisonous snake that she
taunts and gets to bite her,
which allows her to die, so
both Cleopatra and Marc Antony
die in 30 B.C.E., and Octavian now,
really the main power, he kills Caesarion,
who was Cleopatra's
son with Julius Caesar,
as the only possible rival, and
so here we are on 30 B.C.E.,
Octavian is victorious and
then he goes back to Rome
and continues to consolidate his power.
Until we get to 27 B.C.E.,
which is often marked
as the beginning of the Roman Empire,
when Octavian was given the name Augustus,
which means illustrious
one, and from then on,
he will continue to reign
with more and more and more
power that he continues to consolidate
for many, many, many, many more decades.